nearly 90 percent of small businesses
say that sales are still below what they
were before the pandemic
and that's according to the federal
reserve and more asian black or hispanic
owners
say their company's finances are poor or
fair
when you compare them to white business
owners jpmorgan chase recently pledged
350 million dollars to help grow small
businesses run by minority owners
it's all part of the bank's larger 30
billion dollar that's with a b
commitment to help address the racial
wealth divide in this country jamie
dimon is the chairman and ceo of jp
morgan chase and joins us to discuss
good to see you jamie dimon i love the
numbers they're very impressive
350 million good to see you
30 billion and now this new commitment
includes 40 million for over
40 million for your entrepreneurs of
color fun first start us off by telling
us why this
initiative is important to you
personally
yeah so gail welcome thrilled to be here
you know look we have
we saw covid uh we saw the murder of
george floyd
uh we've had racial inequality in this
country and this highlighted it
for a hundred years and i think it's
time for all of us to double down and
try to help
the rest of the community small business
black entrepreneurs
latinx entrepreneurs asian entrepreneurs
they need a little more money they need
a little more help a little more
consulting
so we've learned a lot as we try to help
businesses in detroit which i remember
talking about once
you know we went into detroit we helped
a hundred small businesses grow
and so this effort you're talking about
today is simply taking that to chicago
la south bronx all around the country
expanding it so exactly how does it work
jamie
well we go to a local community uh we
work with local people like within
detroit with kresge
uh and we make available capital to you
know sometimes it's a grant and
sometimes it's a loan
but to a small business so like in
detroit there were restaurants
there was a lady who started a gym they
wanted to expand there was a contractor
who wanted to expand who
had a government contract but they
needed the capital to finance it if you
want to visit the government you have to
show
that you have the wherewithal and so we
went in and we got them the help they
needed it might be a lawyer it might be
an accountant
but it certainly was a loan and helped
them expand and it's a wonderful thing
and a lot of those business members they
hire locally
so it helps the community twice yeah
they expand as a business and they hire
locally
jamie it's anthony uh i i wanted to ask
you about the the banking business which
which is not known for its diversity
what are you doing at jp morgan chase to
ensure diversity in the company
yeah so we we've been working on
diversity for a long time in fact
we've doubled down that too so like
black eds and md's in this company are
up 50
in the last three years hiring training
recruiting
half of my direct reports are women and
we just had a woman who was a fabulous
woman was running our
whole retail system as part of my
management committee who just left to
run another company but we're doing
everything we can to this company to
help
the black community you were part of a
group of business leaders that met with
president biden vice president harris
and treasury secretary yellen uh
recently
did you talk about the the democrats 1.9
trillion dollar
stimulus bill and how do you feel about
it do you think it's
enough do you think it's too much
yeah so we did so first of all i was
grateful the president and the vice
president had us in
there were four ceos in the room we
spent almost two hours
and we actually covered a lot of ground
from the from that bill to
immigration to taxation to and i love
the fact he brought
american competitiveness we need to make
sure america is competitive for the next
hundred years and
not just to get through covet so uh i'll
leave the bill itself we need
more help for those who really need it
unemployed mothers who had to leave the
workforce to go home to take care of
family members
or children uh small businesses who you
know really need the help to get through
this and
i'll leave the details to democrats and
republicans to debate
but there's a lot of stimulus it's going
to get us through us and thank god we
have this vaccine
so i'm hoping when we all get to june
and the flowers are coming out then
and people are getting their shots that
we can get back to a normal life and
the stimulus will lead in my view to a
very
very strong economy late this year and
into next year
and maybe even into 2023. jamie you
certainly have a reputation of playing
nicely with
others do you find a difference in
working with this administration
compared to the last administration
yeah well kale might you know my job to
do the best i can for my company my
country and i'm a patriot
and i will work with any president to do
the best i can for
for america so uh i you know to me it's
always good when
politicians speak to each other you know
look you know my friend and your friend
vernon jordan
the boy was one of the great human
beings of all time
and what did we learn from him is talk
to other people treat them with respect
you know get into the details you know
try to get everyone advancing in society
you know i like what you just said about
being a patriot there was rumors on the
streets
that you were thinking about running for
president in 2020 does president diamond
have a ring to you
down the road i i i'm i
i i i i what's the answer jamie dimon
i'm not going to run for president well
that's emphatic jamie dimon thank you
very much for joining us
this morning thank you jamie dimon